[Musique]
avec son climat chaud et sec l'australie
est souvent la proie d'un incendie qui
ravage des brousses et les forêts chaque
année des milliers d'hectares de
végétation sur la proie des flammes
mais dans ce continent les pompiers font
face à un obstacle supplémentaire
pendant qu'ils s'acharnent à combattre
ces feux des pyromanes safer plus tôt et
propager
[Musique]
il s'agit d'oiseaux de proie surnommé
des faucons de flux
[Musique]
lors d'un incendie il leur arrive de
ramasser des brindilles en flammes dans
leur bec ou dans leurs pattes
puis ils les laissent tomber dans des
zones qui ne sont pas encore touchés par
les flammes
parfois jusqu'à un kilomètre plus loin
ils peuvent être des dizaines à la fois
répété ce manège de manière coordonnée
il leur arrive même de voler des brady
dans des feux de cuisson a du nez par
l'humain
au moins trois espèces agissent ainsi
le milan noir le milan siffleur et le
faucon brrr
pourquoi ces rapaces veulent t'ils
propager ainsi les incendies la réponse
est simple pour trouver des proies
lorsqu'une forêt s'embrase les animaux
qu'elle abrite traîne la fuite
les rapaces peuvent alors capturer les
petits oiseaux
les rongeurs les reptiles et les
insectes qui sortent de leur abri
ce comportement est connu depuis des
millénaires par les populations
aborigènes et le faucon de feu fait même
partie de la mythologie locale
les autorités australiennes étaient
sceptiques jusqu'à ce que le géographe
américain marc pinta et l'ornithologue
australien robert kraft foods se posent
sur le phénomène
après des années d'observation
méticuleuse à travers plusieurs régions
du pays
ces chercheurs ont confirmé ce que
savaient les peuples aborigènes ces
oiseaux de proie transporte délibérément
des tisons vers des zones de végétation
que le feu n'a pas encore atteint leur
étude a été publiée dans le jo long flot
biology les chercheurs croient que ce
phénomène pourrait aussi se produire en
amérique du sud et en afrique
cette découverte démontre que les
humains ne sont pas des seuls à avoir
appris à maîtriser le feu pour assurer
leur survie